was the last time you spoke to
government about trying to get this
strike resolved
I think we spoke to government back in
January it's been many months the
government is trying to remain aloof but
of course in the contracts they have
with the train operating companies
they are directly responsible and
they're responsible for this deadlock
and responsible for the fact that
there's not a settlement they've cost
the country nearly 5 billion pounds in
the course of this dispute they've given
the train operating companies 900
million pounds in subsidies and they've
allowed them to pay 160 million pounds
of dividends over the last two years so
they're entirely responsible but they're
like Pontius Pilate they want to wash
their hands of it I mean they would of
course say that you and your members
have crossed the country by by going out
on strike you say there's an impasse and
the government are the ones being the
roadblock what is it exactly that the
government aren't allowing the
relatively group to do
well the government as as contracts with
all these companies that say that the
Secretary of State Mark Harper is
directly responsible for industrial
relations they negotiating stance and
the conduct of the dispute so they are
demanding that our members put up with
below inflation pay Rises we haven't had
a pay rise for four years now and
they've offered five percent when
inflation over that period has probably
been 25 they want to cut thousands of
jobs out of the system they want to shut
every book in office in Britain they
want to get rid of catering they want to
get rid of engineering jobs and so
there's a whole host of changes that
they want to bring in which will be
detrimental to the public and the
service on the railway and the railway's
future and they're directly responsible
for that but of course they've got got a
dogmatic approach to workers wages
they're making working people poorer all
over the country and everywhere outside
of Mark Harper's remit we've got
settlements we've got settlements in
Scotland we've got settlements in Wales
we've got even got settlements with the
private sector rail operators and the
bus companies and everybody else we deal
with except where the Tory government
can controls the industry we've got no
settlement and we've got strikes I mean
you had a list there of things that are
part of the problem in the negotiations
so it's it's more than pay I mean the
last time we spoke there are a couple of
things that were really at the heart of
this you said it was it was driver only
operated trains and the shutting of of
um of ticket officers but you expanded
the list there where is this because the
negotiation is gonna have to come down
to a couple of things isn't it at some
point
foreign
companies directly where they've got
their business and their reputation and
their Capital at stake they make
settlements the fact is that the
government is subsidizing this they want
to drive through changes that we believe
will be detrimental to our people who
work on the railway but also detrimental
to the passengers that use it we want a
thriving Railway we want a railway
that's safe for every man and woman in
the country and for people to travel for
disabled people they won't allow that
because they've got a dogmatic approach
but you know they're doing this in every
sector they're doing it in our
Children's Schools they're doing it in
hospitals they're driving down wages
they're driving
standards down and it's based on the
fact that they they want to make people
poorer to drive down this inflation rate
and we haven't contributed to inflation
because our members haven't had a pay
rise for four years so we can't have
caused this price spiral so we need to
get on with negotiating a sensible
agreement and if if the government can
enable that will be a good faith partner
but we need to to have a room for
maneuver so that we can create a
settlement of course they would dispute
that they want to make people poorer
make it as you know and talking about
they are making people poor all over the
country
impoverished all over the country
and you've and you've made that
appointment but you know people are
going to be traveling all around the
country this weekend for a number of
huge events as you well know the FA Cup
Final there's a Beyonce concert in
London and you're going to be ruining
their weekend by your guys being out
strike
well that's not what we
people defend their standard of living
and defend their jobs we don't want to
ruin people attending Beyonce or the FA
Cup or anything else last year the
railway decided to close uh the entire
West Coast which most of those people
will be using on Cup final day so they
don't they don't care about football
fans or pop pop fans they don't care
about anything apart from propping up
private sector operators on the railway
so if we can get a settlement we can get
the railway running again and that's
what we're looking for we're available
night and day to negotiate a deal on
this this dispute but we need a
counterpart in order to do that